those private properties hurt
it certainly is private property not
your property sir mrs. Henderson called
she said there's a black man dressed up
like a cow on crack cocaine harassing
and goat she did yeah she did that goat
was arrested me pray with me that go
really what is it go Satyam why did it
go so he said amen way up in this pin
which it could I know you're in a cow I
said the story doesn't check out the
story doesn't check out once he said but
what is the chamber that see black man
she's a costume crack cocaine harassing
my goats trespassing on my property okay
you know what let's refute those one by
one okay I'm a little futile one by one
crackhead
I can't refute that one okay dress up
like a cow alright I'm open to ting fine
harassing my goats that I didn't do
because I saw you doing a man I was over
here this month this little don't pardon
him yeah son of a bitch god dammit god
dammit right god damn the crack makes it
fast he's headed straight to straight to
Mountain Lion country
you know what they'll take care of him
my old lines will get him it's a circle
of life
[Music]